hey what's going on is Bilborough and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday December 9th 2019 what is
going on how are you how's it going how
are you doing I know people in Kansas
City hey you [ __ ] molasses BBQ eating
[ __ ] how sticky of your [ __ ]
faces right now weave congratulations to
you long-suffering [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
western part of Missouri I know you
[ __ ] probably got an extra [ __ ]
order of [ __ ] baby back ribs young
reason why I'm doing this to you guys
with the food thing is for some reason
that's just what you have to do in
sports like they always think you know
everybody in Boston's eatin [ __ ] clam
chowder or some [ __ ] stupid seafood
dish you know baked beans you know every
time [ __ ] fillies in some sort of
[ __ ] big-time game
what are they always got to teach the
rest of the world how to order a cheese
steggy gonna give me a whiz wish go [ __ ]
you skip me a Philadelphia cheesesteak
I can't wait to [ __ ] go there again
and just say the whole [ __ ] order
just make the [ __ ] thing you can't
you got to say give me one win one
without oh do I
is that what I am I'm a [ __ ] money's
green anyway yeah this is what I was
talking about early in the [ __ ]
season I kind of saw this second half
coming just Gronkowski not being there
and we do not have a legit number two
threat and these guys are just not
stepping up and they're [ __ ] double
in Edelman and then we get threes and
outs and then our defense gets tired and
you can't do that
teams in the NFL just making I don't
know droppin balls and [ __ ] not
picking up at there's a blitz and
breaking off your route or at least
looking back at Brady they're just not
doing it and our offense is [ __ ]
anemic now I know there was some
questionable calls but they make [ __ ]
up calls at both sides I [ __ ] hate
blaming the refs so you know [ __ ] you
know I talked to virzi I wish I brought
that up because he was the guy he told
me early in the season goes Pats are
gonna do it again - [ __ ] defense it's
unbelievable it's like dude we're
playing the dregs of the NFL I think I
would hedge my bet until we you know we
see you know where we're at you know we
had a Antonio Brown for like a [ __ ]
week and you know then that all went to
[ __ ] and we still have a gaping [ __ ]
hole that's just you know Edelman is our
threat everybody knows it and then they
double them up and then that's kind of
been [ __ ] it so I am still sticking
with my Super Bowl pics that I don't do
until November
I don't like get these [ __ ] people
who try to do it at the beginning the
year I mean so why don't you go go try
to hit a full court shot you don't know
what the [ __ ] anybody's gonna do you
really don't
oh they picked up this guy they lost
that guy yeah you know [ __ ] you got to
watch him play for a couple months so I
still think it's going to be the Ravens
against the Seahawks oh oh the Seahawks
made me a little nervous tonight they
did not have a good game or even look
good against the the LA Rams huge win
for the Rams and a [ __ ] big huge
[ __ ] loss for the Seattle Seahawks
they were in the driver's seat to have
[ __ ] home field they already beat the
49ers in San Francisco and then they
were gonna have to come to their [ __ ]
loud-ass Stadium and now they [ __ ]
that up so that last game of the year is
going to be huge so now if Seattle and
49ers both win the rest of the way out
they play each other the last game in
the air I believe and that's gonna be in
Seattle oh that's gonna be a big [ __ ]
game that is going to be a big game but
I just think
I don't know the reason why I'm picking
Seattle over the 49ers this is my logic
is I just feel like they both have
incredible teams with talent both sides
of the ball and I always think that when
that is the deal it's gonna come down to
the coach and I just think Pete Carroll
is the best coach he's a better coach at
this point I mean I might be wrong I
don't know [ __ ] about the 49ers guys but
Pete has been there so I just think he's
gonna come up with a game plan and as
long as everybody stays healthy I think
he can get him but if they go on the
road again in the playoffs and have to
go back to San Francisco who knows who
knows what the [ __ ] had happened but uh
Patriots are on the outside look at
enemy we're at the point right thud the
[ __ ] Buffalo Bills could win the
division so it's been a long time since
you know I've just seen like you know
people usually play above their level
and and I would think I don't know what
the Pats that's kind of what we need
with everybody else in the receiving
corps that isn't Edelman he kind of got
you got to give this guy you got to give
them a reason to put him in single
coverage or it's it's an hour it's been
a [ __ ] you know it's it's been uphill
for them that's just how it's been but
Kansas City they came into Foxborough
and they [ __ ] beat the Pats even
after we went up seven to nothing they
came back so you got to give it to them
and my home's fighting through that
[ __ ] hand and injury so no [ __ ]
sour grapes here with that one all right
Raider fans still crying about the
[ __ ] tuck rule this is how a man
takes a loss anyway I've been a tough
[ __ ] sports weekend here for me I
watched the [ __ ] Avalanche come in
Jesus Christ went up 1-nothing what a
[ __ ] team they got big fast and some
snipers on that team I think they got
you know they got that kid I mean what's
[ __ ] Amos but so damn busy since it
became a dad but I know it's either that
kid was on a Avila
McDavid on Edmonton as far as the best
guy in the league a lot of people are
saying but I was very impressed with
them they kind of reminded me of those
great LA King teams earlier in this
decade where they were just just really
big and really [ __ ] fast I don't
think they had I don't think they didn't
Kings teams had the speeds of what I saw
with the Avalanche the replay of the
game as much as I watched it but all
right so what are you gonna do let's get
back to NFL football here the 49ers win
forty eight to forty six against the
[ __ ] New Orleans Saints and for some
reason everybody's all excited about the
49ers I I would not be excited as a 49er
fan that he led up 46 [ __ ] points to
a team that he could possibly see in the
playoffs I would not be excited you
should never be excited when when you
[ __ ] him possibly the game of the
year
yeah on one side of the ball other than
that it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show they let
up 90 because defenses combined let up
94 [ __ ] points I don't know I'm
always excited about that but hey won
the SEC championship that championship
they beat Georgia 37 to 10
Ohio State wins the Big Ten by beating
Wisconsin 3421 now as far as I can tell
the way the NCAA works here considering
LSU won easily manhandled Georgia by 27
[ __ ] points and the fact that OSU
only won by 13 points then does LSU now
become number one because I remember
when they beat number one Alabama in
Alabama but [ __ ] OSU put up 70 points
on that powerhouse Maryland they somehow
but I will never understand the [ __ ]
NCAA how they decide because here's the
thing I'm not saying LSU could be Ohio
State you know we can figure that out is
if they play each other but I just don't
understand how I Oh state beating Penn
State you know LSU were they beaten like
[ __ ] three or four teams in the top
ten
had a way way harder schedule I don't
understand it but that's just how
college football is and you know what
they have a playoff system thank [ __ ]
god because back in the day OSU would
have just won the national championship
I guess they still would have had to win
that ballgame at least LSU and OSU will
play each other and I have no idea how
that will go down I don't watch enough
college ball to even predict it so who
knows maybe they're right maybe OSU is
better than LSU I have no idea but if
LSU wins with that would be pretty great
for Jo burrows the team that wouldn't
couldn't give him any [ __ ] time but I
mean he can't get mad at OSU I mean
they're loaded with [ __ ] talent the
fact that the guy that couldn't even get
on the [ __ ] field is now gonna win a
Heisman Trophy possibly for somebody
else's so what do you guys been doing I
feel like I'm doing all the talking here
tell me about you guys what do you been
doing I you gonna leave been going to
your Christmas party is it an amazing
thing when you get older you know you
get to the end of the [ __ ] year and
there's all these Christmas parties when
you're young they're fun go there get
shit-faced maybe get laid get a [ __ ]
humma as they used to say back in
Beantown Dodi gave him a [ __ ] AMA dude
she gave my Hummer what am I talking
about here maybe I was progressive way
to say it
dude she gave him a [ __ ] Hummer in
the backseat of his [ __ ] Chrysler
Cordoba
now when you get older it's like you get
there you got kids you [ __ ] show up
you're already tired [ __ ] Christmas
party but it's like playing the Thursday
night game in the NFL will you still
[ __ ] sore from four days ago but it's
been fun man it's Christmas parties out
here in LA have fun you've run into all
these [ __ ] people that are uh you
don't see cuz they're they're Road Dogg
and you're Road Dogg and so I got to run
to a bunch of comics then I don't get to
hang out with that much and we get a
couple more coming up so it's been good
so far I gotta get my [ __ ] Christmas
shopping going I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna get
no [ __ ] idea you know do I do what
all you guys do do I just order it on
the Internet all right let's let's look
this [ __ ] up let's let's help let's help
myself out and possibly you guys out
let's look at a top Christmas gifts of
2019 for her you know it's funny let me
let me go back here for let's see for
teens for kids for her for girls for men
there it is one two three four five all
ranked fifth we you you can go home sir
after your ball game then it's toddlers
then team boys young adults wife we
already said her didn't we and then mom
okay that's the top one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten that's the
NCAA top ten [ __ ] gifts all right
what do I go for wives so he go wives
are her let's go her first let's see
what what hers are getting for [ __ ]
Christmas all right
aquamarine necklace I don't even know
what that is but women do not want some
seafaring horse [ __ ] don't buy that you
know this is all [ __ ] money is
throwing it okay gifts for her 37 bit
best gift ideas for ladies and 2019 this
is just gonna be all clickbait let's see
what's beneath this fifty four best
gifts for men the men in your life
twenty five super thoughtful gifts not
gifts for foodies this might be
legitimate
Walmart's ultimate hot holiday toy list
for twenty nine what the [ __ ] do they
Sentinel selling a Walmart a shove a
jacket do they make those for toddlers
now these are just all creepy dolls they
got [ __ ] toys at Walmart one of these
pure [ __ ] pee
trampling themselves trampling other
[ __ ] Americans to go get xoxo friends
multipack surprise you can have a
[ __ ] herniated disk over that [ __ ]
you know I just what it could I don't
know you don't you know it's funny you
shop at Walmart that's literally like
going to the bad part of town and you
get mugged I mean I feel bad for you but
it went what you know at some point it's
like what do you what are you going down
there at two o'clock in the morning for
what did you think was gonna happen all
right here we go 37 gift ideas for every
woman in your life
a leather pocket wallet 1699 all right I
got to get out of it what the [ __ ] are
we doing what did we you in seventh
grade you can't buy a seventeen dollar
gift for a woman jesus [ __ ] christ
you know you know them it's all about
[ __ ] you buy it it cost a lot of
money and then they wear it in front of
their friends look what my [ __ ] got me
no I'm sorry
come on bill all right top to 2019 gifts
all right what are we what are we doing
this is just all [ __ ]
aquamarine necklace again I'm starting
to believe this here you go honey I
bought you an aqua marine necklace cuz I
know how much you love the [ __ ] sea
all right Jesus Christ this is [ __ ]
bad man
but we in a recession what's going on
here five dollar credit no thanks I need
a five dollar credit on a 17 dollar
necklace long-distance touch bracelet
set Vesper massage necklace wine cork
States you know boy these are [ __ ]
terrible I wouldn't even put these in a
stocking you don't think about a
stocking stuffer that gift you're like
ashamed of let's just stick this in a
[ __ ] sock nobody will see it
you know you get the big gift sort of
the big gift is like a [ __ ] easiest
person into the [ __ ] horseshit they
gave you
haircare holder all right I am in the
wrong part of the internet here top 10
Christmas gifts we do they have a list
wit that she's gonna like top Christmas
gifts for expensive let's say expensive
top expensive Christmas gifts let's just
keep it unisex shall we most excited is
40 best luxury gifts for him Jesus
Christ let's see what this is I don't
know what this it calvess see use
lingotto caviar it's 99 bucks that's a
lot of money for some fish eggs right to
pelo honey gold reserve what am i a
[ __ ] chef what do they weigh tap beer
dispenser it's a hundred 19 bucks
National Park dog bed this is for guys
what if when he's an [ __ ] you make
him go sleep on the dog bed be print
silk twill pocket square out of 45 bucks
all right that's okay all right we see
the wheel house still keeping it on the
200 bucks for the ladies let's see what
you got for they got top expensive gifts
for her that aquamarine [ __ ] necklace
staying strong all right
chic expensive gifts for the lady in
your life all right cross over wide ring
with diamonds eight on it 72 five bucks
Daisy cental scented candle $36 they're
all over the map here chocolate truffles
99 bucks these are [ __ ] terrible
gifts by the way enriched body scrub
yeah once you put this on your stinky
[ __ ] [ __ ] faux fur throw blanket
petite mom all leather wallet on a chain
895 bucks and get her some flats for
$120 look creme main hand creams 50
bucks 18 karat gold pave diamond initial
necklace what is she a rapper my the
[ __ ] would you get her that that's 500
bucks Jesus Christ siren wire earrings
all right I am no closer to knowing what
to get my I don't [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] know I thought that they were
gonna have all those you know Jesus this
is such a stupid [ __ ] goddamn time of
the year it really is put on an itchy
sweater and try and go buy me some [ __ ]
you know what the greatest gift you can
tell so what do you want for christmas
nothing why don't we watch a movie we'll
get some of that blockbuster popcorn if
they still [ __ ] make it right we'll
just sit here we'll [ __ ] eat that
next to our you know get the heater
going maybe get a fireplace where you
live
why don't we do that and [ __ ] all this
other [ __ ] just just buy [ __ ] for your
[ __ ] kids right let's see let's let's
see what I can get of a kid top ten
dangerous toys for kids 20 19 all right
10 dangerous toys of 2019 shoppers
checklist twice all right what do we got
here I don't know what this is but the
kids holding it up to his eye
how can a nerf thing be nerf ultra one
the blaster that fires up to 120 feet
has the pent potential for eye injuries
no it does and it's made out of nerf
nerf is soft right spike the fine motor
Hedgehog hard plastic removable quills
and the potential for ingestion injuries
in choking bunchems
bunch of build plastic connective pieces
may get entangled in hair and make us
check I can see that choking but
entangled in hair with the [ __ ]
you're kind of reaching for [ __ ] there
Yeti the stuffed animals long hair may
come out and be ingested or cause
aspiration Nickelodeon's frozen treats
slime I need to read that one I already
know that's why would you it's not even
food right they look like a smoothie
soft-serve ice cream or a snow cone but
the package warns that they're not real
food and shouldn't be eaten diecast
School Bus the rubber tires a removal
could cause choking if you kids old
enough to put play with a [ __ ] bus
he's gonna stick the tires in him well
maybe they've got a younger sibling I
don't [ __ ] know you guys see that
Ruiz fight am I saying it right Ruiz
Ruiz and watch that thing came on it
like [ __ ] 10 in the goddamn morning
that's one of those annoying fights
where you know that the the former champ
did what he was supposed to do you know
if this guy's a brawler you're a boxer
so he just kind of pointed him to death
I thought she had to knock out the champ
to get here they like beat him can I
guess he he pointed him he never really
hurt the guy and then the [ __ ] guy
you watching this is exactly what he
needs to do gotta score some points and
then get the [ __ ] out of there I know
fight fans aren't enjoying this yeah we
want to see a fight you want to see
somebody get knocked the [ __ ] out that's
what you want to [ __ ] see I know that
the former champ now the champ did what
the [ __ ] he's supposed to be doing
but jesus [ __ ] christ peaceful he
fought a smart fight
hey Jesus [ __ ] I mean I I got to take
somebody now somebody who's never been
in the ring before I'm gonna tell you
why I didn't like that fight sorry all
right it's time for the advertising here
by the way I'm recording this thing
[ __ ] super late at night I went out
and did some stand-up and I came back my
wife was already asleep and I actually
tried to get back quick as I would learn
to watch TV with her and stuff that she
was already asleep so what are you gonna
do I'm not gonna wake her up
you know tell [ __ ] it I'll come down
here but I did some stay in a pen don't
stand up like [ __ ] 8 days because
I've been studying for this goddamn test
and I went down and uh my buddy was
saying Jeff Ross has his [ __ ] room
down on Ventura Avenue I was like god
[ __ ] he's gonna room so I went down
there and I Drive by and it says the
roastmaster something outside this venue
I'm like holy [ __ ] II bought a [ __ ]
comedy club and I walked in turnout was
just an empty store and he just he just
had it for like 48 hours and he had a
like a food truck and was like a free
show and all that it was a [ __ ] great
time you know standing-room-only and all
of that [ __ ] and I went onstage and he
had a mic and we were kind of onstage
sort of together doing kind of the Dave
Attell Jeff Ross bumpin mic thing I've
never done that with them I had like the
best [ __ ] time I felt like that was
most of the set then I kind of shook off
some cobwebs because I got the Vegas
show coming up on the 21st so I'm doing
stand-up every night until then so I
don't [ __ ] you know lay an egg and
when I go out to Vegas speaking of which
I got some I got some tour dates to
announce here upcoming dates all on sale
new orleans tickets almost sold out for
the Mahalia Jackson theatre On January
9th I got the Patrice O'Neal benefit is
January 27th at the New York City Center
Theatre and they have some new ones that
we just added sorry
Santa Ynez Santa Ynez California the
Chumash kiss
Resort on February 7th then I'm doing
the Vancouver in Vancouver and we be at
the Queen Elizabeth Theatre February
21st doing two shows and then I'm in
Nashville Tennessee at the Grand Ole
Opry House legendary Grand Ole Opry
House on April 13th cannot wait for
those gigs that's gonna be fun I can't
wait to get back out on the road guys
I've been [ __ ] oh my god guys did I
just say guys I can't get wait to get
back on the road guys
you guys have been so patient just
waiting for my dick and [ __ ] jokes to be
coming your way yeah I didn't work a lot
this this fall like I kind of been
building but the act back up and it's I
think it's where it needs to be but at
some point you got to go back out on the
road and just start doing [ __ ]
hour-long steps and everything and I
started to do that but then you know the
holidays I like to try to be around and
all that [ __ ] so we got our Christmas
tree we haven't put the lights up yet
just bugging me cuz it's already the 9th
so we got to get the [ __ ] lights on
tomorrow we got all of this [ __ ] going
on and but you don't care about that
right I got a while you know I've been
doing lately though I've been taking my
daughter everywhere I go when I leave
the house I was so [ __ ] afraid to do
it for so long and I was talking to a
buddy money said he had a son and he's
like you know he's a great kid now he's
like 30 years old he goes I just take my
son everywhere I went it's like I got to
do that more often so Larry's so I took
her to the grocery store today cuz we
were all out of eggnog I [ __ ] love
eggnog I know that's a very it's a
hot-button issue people either love it
they hate it like eggnog is like the
Trump spirit of [ __ ] the holidays I
love that [ __ ] I mean I don't pour a
giant glass of it but I you know oh I
used to love it with brandy oh ho ho you
get the fireplace going it's [ __ ]
delicious
it's like spiked ice cream so I was
going down there to get more eggnog and
then we needed some more other [ __ ]
right and then think to us and you buy
eggnog you can only buy one container of
it cuz you don't know how it's gonna go
cuz it's also something you get real
sick up real quickly because it's
[ __ ] super sweet so I went down there
and I was like I'm gonna bring my
bleep daughter Oh so we go down there
and she's at that age now will you take
her down the aisles and she's seen all
the food she likes you know I want dad
to I want goldfish you know and that's
so smart they put like Toy Story she
knows that you know she knows woody and
all those guys now you know Lightning
McQueen she's seen all those Pixar
movies Disney movies and all of that
shit's and they just put him on the food
and you just [ __ ] you're [ __ ] you're
going down the aisle and you're trying
to be like we already have goldfish at
home I wanna go for water you're like
all right buddy everybody I'm not gonna
be like and then you can't put it in the
cart they got to hold on to it it's
hilarious they hold on to it like they
won an Emmy or something so I learned
that I brought it down to the grocery
store it's like alright let's go down
her aisle let's get her a little bagger
that's something that she wants and
she'll hold on to that and then I can go
dude I'm so sorry I'm [ __ ] Jana like
this but I got an early morning tomorrow
so I this is the only time I could do
this [ __ ] so we went that she's just the
best man she's the best that she's so
[ __ ] funny like she actually
understands humor already you know like
I was trying to put a clothes on today
when she was deliberately making it
difficult she just kept laughing and I
was like can you just stop can you stop
doing that she kept you know moving her
legs
like she does a thing you know she puts
her foot straight up so it won't go down
the [ __ ] pant leg and she sees me get
frustrated she just sits there laughing
at me and she did it so much this
morning that I finally just quit and I
just made like a pout face or whatever
the hoping that that would work and then
she just goes dad die I want you be
happy looks like alright well can you
help me out here and she just laughed
and she kind of let me do it but like
the fact that she knew and then and then
she [ __ ] with me again it was like
this is like a comedian being like
alright alright I'll leave you alone
whatever they're doing that was bugging
you
she just like keeps doing it it's like
funniest [ __ ] ever and I don't know I
don't know how I can't keep a [ __ ]
straight and then the worst thing is
then she starts making me laugh while
she's annoying the hell out of me
because I can't get her stupid you know
sweatpants on or whatever cute cutest
little frigging sweatpants ever but I
don't know she's the best man she's the
best so it's been great to be home all
this time but I I you know I do need to
get back out on the road so anyways
let's do so breeds here I'm figuring
like if I yawn really aggressively that
the tiredness is gonna go away it's also
like [ __ ] 20 after 12:00 here alright
oh here we go but do do me on DS be on
DS oh I like [ __ ] eggnog do you do to
be on DS be on DS if it rains you get
soggy socks life [ __ ] it all up
nothing rhymes with nog important some
what do you put what do you put it in
eggnog what's that brown [ __ ]
nutmeg um it's just a bad road nothing
rhymes nutmeg put some [ __ ] get some
eggnog with nutmeg aren't you really
glad you don't have a wooden leg drink
it up
put a little brandy in there and then
yell at people who don't deserve it next
to a fire me undies by this time of year
the plan is it virgos of the world have
checked off everything on their list I
don't know what any of that means while
the rest of us last-minute people are
running around like psychos trying to
figure out what to get everyone well
that is me Oh a virgos planners is this
like astrology I thought that was some
[ __ ] super rich family like the
asters or the Rothschilds the virgos
anyway let's go don't fear fellow
last-minute gift restore elasticity
everyone on your list covered it's the
one-stop shopping spot to get gifts that
people that people will actually love
delivered straight to your door free
shipping no buts about it actually all
buts about it because it's undies you
get it it's cold out but honey it's
called outside it's dark out at like 4
p.m. I feel so bad for that guy that
wrote honey it's cold outside you know
what I mean did he get to weigh in at
all and be like I wasn't writing about
rape me undies wants me why do people
who didn't write the song get to say
what it's about me undies wants you to
know that it's okay to not leave the
house as much this winter in sizes XS
all the way up to 4 XL with plenty of
brand-new products the options for
getting cozy undies do I have to hit
pause here when I [ __ ] you on so I
don't make you all you guys tired the
option for getting cozy are endless when
they say cozy they mean it with the
undies that are three times softer than
cotton in the cutest wintery prints and
colors that's like really soft alright
many the undies has a great offer from
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because we have a 100% satisfaction
guarantee to get you 15% off your first
pair free shopping at one percent
satisfaction guarantee go to the undies
comm / / that's me undies comm / /
oh look who's back just in time for me
to yarn it's all zip hiring is
challenging but there's one place where
you could go where hiring is simple fast
and SMAT and growing businesses
connected to quality candidates I feel
like something was missing in their Co
dabble co-founded Gretchen
[ __ ] nur what Oh
codable co-founder gretchen [ __ ] nur
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
new game artist to grow with her
education tech company but then she
switched to zip recruiter and saw an
immediate difference and you - by
signing up and you can't - sorry by
signing up for the free zip career.com /
/ zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you and by using zip they're screening
questions to filter candidates Gretchen
found it easier to focus on the best
ones in fact after posting her job on
zip cruder Gretchen said she was
honestly surprised she found qualified
applicants so quickly and hired a new
game artist in less than two weeks with
results like that it's not wonderful
four out of five employees who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day zip the smartest
way to hire cy zip recruiter is affected
for is effective for businesses of all
trial sizes tricep recruiting for free
at our website address zip recruit comm
/ / that's zip recruiter comm /b you are
are all right let's get into the
questions here you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna have them edit out
that [ __ ] I said about rape in the
middle of [ __ ] that last one I might
have to take that out and if he did take
it out now you listen to saying what did
you say I made a [ __ ] zip recruiter
comment about you know this certain ride
service app should have you zip
recruiter because then they could screen
it for [ __ ] rapist right that's the
way I'll say I don't feel like in the
suit here alright the irishman bill love
your work and I typically think you are
hilarious
okay I'll take that it's 5:45 a.m. and I
am on my morning walk and you just told
everyone how amazing the the irishman I
think you meant to say is they
is amazing Goodfellas is my favorite
movie alta is my favorite all-time movie
all capital letters I cannot believe you
like that boring garbage movie my word
it makes me question everything about
you
parentheses mostly kidding all right you
didn't like it oh just [ __ ] people it
didn't like Goodfellas I mean it didn't
win an Oscar that year that's how it is
it's art is you know it's in the [ __ ]
eye of the beholder he goes I thought
only reason that that I thought only
reason Jesus Christ dude if you're gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a Scorsese [ __ ] movie
that was as great as this one you can't
even spell check I thought only reason
people liked that movie is to kiss ass
to the elderly director director and
woke cast okay a woke cast I don't you
know what that means but you generally
seem to like it how is that possible
well I you know I'm sure there's movies
that you like that I don't like
compare that to good felt Goodfellas or
even Casino and tell me that movie is in
the same [ __ ] universe bill just
checking in on you please leave la
before it's too late
I love people's [ __ ] I was so many
people's perception on what la is is
what people have told them what it is
and none of them know what the [ __ ] it
is all right la is a [ __ ] incredible
goddamn city all right so enough already
and you just think it's everybody out
here with Botox and fake tits just [ __ ]
[ __ ] walking around just being a
phony [ __ ] jackass that's that's not
what it is
that's you know I mean it's everywhere
you go to Chicago does everybody have a
[ __ ] mustache going ad get bears and
[ __ ] stick in their face at a
deep-dish pizza hey when it boss today
let's go get some chowder so dump I
absolutely [ __ ] loved that movie that
I just watched it again and I love I
love it even more
it's [ __ ] and cry mean I don't know
what movie you watched
so I don't know I agree to disagree I
mean you really didn't bring you really
didn't criticize it boring garbage movie
wow that's that's a little [ __ ] harsh
alright okay but you did say you liked
Goodfellas so you're not one of those
superhero because I know the superhero
people really got upset when Scorsese
was saying that that's not cinema which
I would agree with they their movies
I think cinema is like you know it's
like you know night train is a wind
right I guess they're all wines you know
what to me but then it's just you know
this is there's this top-shelf booze
then this [ __ ] that I'll get you drunk
for [ __ ] five dollars that's all he's
saying and some people like it do you
know to get drunk on the cheap [ __ ] so
you're entitled to hey I [ __ ] like
eggnog you know what I mean I absolutely
loved that [ __ ] movie and I I will
watch that movie for the rest of my life
that's how I feel about it if you don't
like it that that's fine
but I think it's a little harsh to say
it's a garbage movie I wouldn't say all
superhero movies are garbage I had one
of my why am i bringing superhero movies
into it you didn't bring that up alright
whatever let's continue all right agree
to disagree sir you didn't like I said
you didn't really critique me I call me
nuts I enjoy watching Al Pacino and
Robert De Niro in doing scenes together
finally
in heat they were only at the table for
[ __ ] 10 seconds I think it's one of
Joe Pesci's greatest if not his greatest
[ __ ] work of all time and whoever
that actor is that played Tony Pro I
mean it's it's instant [ __ ] classic
scenes I don't know what the [ __ ] you
will watch it if I was a younger man and
I had energy and it wasn't so sleepy I'd
actually get upset with you right now
but you know what good you go watch how
to [ __ ] build an American quilt or
whatever that [ __ ] movie is alright
temper advice alright hi Billy
I can't think of anything clever as a
greeting I appreciate you know whatever
you tapped out we all do that I'm a 39
year old lady who was a redhead like
yourself I love it
I love it a fellow redhead we got
another meeting on Tuesday hope you make
it I feel like I have a horrible temper
I have an extremely short fuse and I
think I am pretty pretty easily
irritated by a lot of things I bet it's
how many times in your life have people
blamed your hair you know redheads I got
a short fuse they got that hot hair on
top of their head well my head shaved
down I'm still just as angry my husband
always tells me to calm down
which makes me even more annoyed that's
[ __ ] hilarious I'm not sure why I'm
always so easily pissed off well I think
that that's the mystery when you're an
angry person you have to figure out how
you got that way because babies don't
come out angry you become it's [ __ ]
happens to you anyways my immediate
family is so calm and laid-back and they
don't have red hair oh god are you going
with this [ __ ] old wives tale I know
that there are stereotypes that redheads
have worse
tempers than others yeah and that came
about back when they were like drowning
people because they thought they were
witches I don't know what just happened
I just totally lost this [ __ ] oh
there it is hit I [ __ ] just hit a
button and the whole thing went away
anyways I know there are stereotypes
that redheads have worst tempers than
others however I'm not sure if it's just
me or if it's a redhead thing now I
think when a redhead gets mad there's
the red hair and then our face turns red
and everything becomes red and Red's
considered an angry color so I just
think it's more obvious than somebody
with you know pigment and brown hair
when they flip up anyway I'm not sure
why I'm always so easily pissed off my
immediately I just read this okay ice I
sometimes worry about my attitude and
find myself apologizing for my temper
quite often well okay well if you're
apologizing at least you're aware of it
I'm not sure if it's my personality or
if it's actually a ginger issue I'm not
a raging [ __ ] 24/7 yet I feel like I
lose my cool more than most people I
really do have a good heart and it is
there the majority of the time yet I'm
so easily easy to anger it makes me
wonder sometimes you know sometimes if
you're a good person you have a good
heart and you're generous you you
actually could be really angry because
you expect that other people and a lot
of other people and it doesn't happen
you know what I mean I'm not saying
that's my my excuse but I do know that's
part of my anger it's the lack of common
courtesy and I might be living in a
bubble walking around thinking that I am
a courteous [ __ ] person and I might
getting be getting mad at drivers who
are doing the exact same [ __ ] thing
that I just did and I can't hear the
person behind me yelling I don't know I
haven't figured out what my problem is
yet anyways he goes I would she says I
would love to know your thoughts on
regular people versus the [ __ ] that
us gingers can be I know you've been
trying to work on your temper have you
had any success yes I have I've had a
lot of success if so can you give a
[ __ ] some advice I hope you and your
lovely family have a great Christmas I
love hearing stories about your sweet
little girl best wishes and please do go
[ __ ] yourself you know it's a great
thing to do take time out of your life
to go talk to somebody about it I
started doing that before I did the
movie this summer and I haven't been
back and it's affected me so I'm gonna
that's one of my goals in 2020 is to get
back to talking about that he kind of
got to figure out he was a major
epiphany to me was when my body started
breaking down and I had to start getting
massages to work all the you know 40
years and knots and gristle and all this
[ __ ] from repeated movements and flying
on planes and all of that and
my shoulders were like [ __ ] up all
the time and forward and all of that
from you know years again the [ __ ]
kicked out of me
and also not doing enough back exercises
and too much [ __ ] in the front you know
benshan that's all people did in the
[ __ ] 80s what can you bench what can
you bench and not enough people said you
know what are you doing for your back so
when I got all that worked out and my
shoulders came down and I wasn't all
like folded in towards the front my
chest opened up I felt like a lot of my
[ __ ] just the way I was holding myself
in a defensive sort of posture was
causing me to be and it was weird it was
like what happened to me psychologically
cycle the psychological abuse I think as
a kid [ __ ] with my brain which was
tell him I bought was my body that
something bad was gonna happen so then
my body got locked into this defensive
position which then fed my brain and was
this [ __ ] circle going so when my
body opened up like a lot of the [ __ ]
anger kind of went away and I had this
epiphany that I realized that I'm not
really an angry guy and I just react
with anger and there is a difference
like because I was an angry person
before and I was just walking around
angry and I realized that I had left
that guy behind a long time ago without
really noticing but my default emotion
was anger so you might just have like
and this is really hard to like when you
have a default emotion to try to
reprogram yourself and that's kind of
where I'm at you might have more success
than I have by going to talk to somebody
but I found going to talk to somebody
and and then if you have like a lot of
guilt over how you react to [ __ ] kind of
forgiving yourself for that and seen a
lot of the good [ __ ] that you do can
kind of help you be like I well this is
just like you know it's like no
different than okay
put on 20 pounds I got to take it off
it's like alright I'm acting like an
angry lunatic I really need to [ __ ]
you know and then I talked to your
husband just say this is something I
really want to work on so I know I'm
gonna have to do 90% of the work but if
you can kind of just give me a shout-out
like hey you're doing that thing again I
got a bit my act right now that my
daughter has been helping me because
what's great is she's not afraid of me
which is awesome I've kind of broken
that sort of thing in my family tree and
so she could just kind of just talk to
me and if I start acting like a lunatic
like she kind of puts me in check and
I'll just be like you're right you're
right buddy sorry about that and she's
always like it's okay Todd so I don't
know if he can do that for you you know
that could possibly work out who knows
oh [ __ ] I got to write something down
because that just reminded me something
that I forgot my [ __ ] joke that I put
in there mm-hmm I'll hit pause you don't
[ __ ] sit through this [ __ ] but I hit
pause come on bill for God's sakes you
ever know what all right all right I'm
back okay
yeah if maybe your husband can help you
out but the thing is is you really like
when you go to talk to somebody therapy
or all that you really it's really not
what goes on in therapy is in the
beginning it is but it's really in
between therapy you know what I mean
it's like getting a personal trainer
right you get a personal trainer and
they're showing you all these [ __ ]
exercises you're not gonna get the abs
that you want if you then go out and
you're acting like a [ __ ] idiot
between workouts in eating bad food so
when you go to talk to somebody really
you know you gotta it's in between
sessions if you're not working on
yourself then it's it's a just a big
[ __ ] waste of time and then some poor
other human beings gonna just listen you
dumping your life on them every [ __ ]
week it's a brutal [ __ ] job with
those therapists have all right here we
go my vanity ruined my love life hey
Billiam burrito
rido bill burrito oh I love a [ __ ]
burrito I had a [ __ ] great one the
other day
goddamn it [ __ ] delicious alright to
preface this I'm a straight white a
white male so I'm going to sound pretty
arrogant and I personally have hard
standards on loyalty I think you've been
high standards right I consider even
lusting over someone else while in a
relationship cheating okay
alright that's okay alright so to start
I grew up ugly but I kept working at it
until I was undeniably hot parentheses I
was using with vanity alright do you
want to hear the secret whoever has the
best fer fer moans in the room is the
most attractive is that a [ __ ] word
pH er I don't even come on people you
know I'm dumb why would you do this then
I gotta [ __ ] look this this is us
this is something what is that how do
you say fur moan okay a chemical
substance produced and released into the
environment by an animal especially a
mammal or an insect affecting the
behavior or the psychology of others of
its species
how do firm owns work in people they are
secreted outside the body and they have
influenced the behavior on another
individual I don't know what is this is
this like a [ __ ] is this airborne
Spanish Fly here [ __ ] is this are you
roofing people with your cologne or your
natural scent I don't know okay anyway
there are men with okay let me I guess
he was gonna explain it
with a fun this is a whole thing on fur
moms all right straight white male
person you get it I have the best
whoever has the best firm owns in the
room is the most attractive because you
can't control it fur moans really do
make us go primal it overrides your
logical thinking and brings you back to
the caveman days it took between 17 18
and 19 to get it right it was honestly
because I started doing LSD if you
understand you understand I don't
understand but this is like a file I
want to see the movie of this [ __ ]
whatever the hell you write me here
there was this one day I realized there
is no such thing as loyalty in a
relationship it's only firm owns its
honestly started to bother me about
women it doesn't matter who the woman
was how strong a relationship was or how
loyal she claims to be they are they are
all still tried to actively pursue me
what it doesn't matter who the woman was
how strong her relationship was or how
loyal she claimed to be they all tried
to attractively to actively pursue me
this is because your firm owns don't
forget that men want to [ __ ] your
girlfriend all the time - growing up
ugly is a curse because you still carry
the broken confidence - what are you
talking about dude you're [ __ ] I
thought you were crushing it here this
is [ __ ] nuts
no matter how good I look I'm still
insecure about it
I thought you see you're an ugly guy but
you have these fur moans so that makes
you good-looking I don't get this
I'm also insecure about men pursuing my
girlfriend
it made me insecure and securely think
I'm good-looking but I'm not the
best-looking man in the world there are
men with the same level of fur moans as
me or better this means it doesn't
matter how strong my bond is with the
woman honestly this always makes me so
uncomfortable hanging out
the women in relationships already
partly because I don't want her to
assume I'm going to try to pursue her
and the other part there's at least a
50/50 chance she's going to pursue
pursue me too oh boy did Ron Burgundy
write this I don't know if this makes me
sound insecure or not but the only time
I can hang out with the woman in a
relationship I have to make sure their
significant other is standing right
between us well why don't you not
[ __ ] pursue him all that it has to
happen is a man with the same level of
firm owns or better to walk by my
girlfriend and she'll start pursuing him
dude you know what this reminds me of
you ever hear that Hitler used astrology
to make decisions when he was fighting
his [ __ ] war I don't know what this
firm owned [ __ ] is but you have [ __ ]
you've gone down the rabbit hole here
buddy
anyway let alone lusting over him
parentheses hard loyalty rules oh saying
that you don't but it also goes both
ways - I've done my fault I've done my
fault
- only become what I've done my fault I
think you mean done my part I have done
my fault - only because of fur moans so
from what I consider there is no such
thing as loyalty in a relationship which
sucks for me because I do consider
loyalty as the most important part of
relationship and I just find out it's
all cake it's a lie I really need to
find a way to be okay with that in order
to move on from from my love life do you
have any advice yet that [ __ ] you
should be single dude you should be
single for a [ __ ] while and whatever
this firm owned [ __ ] [ __ ] is that
you're talking about I would try and
work this out because you're not going
to be a fun person to be in a
relationship with whatever the [ __ ] that
was
about how you know you have these great
firm owns and you walk in there and you
[ __ ] you know but I think you're
putting out a vibe all right you're a
good-looking guy you're putting out a
vibe and women a [ __ ] responding to
it and you know I don't know I don't
know what world you're in if you're in a
bar how old you are I don't know what's
going on here but you know I learned a
new word I don't have any advice for you
I don't I don't really understand what
you're talking about you're saying that
basically it's all based on sense and
because you have this incredible [ __ ]
scent that Calvin Klein would love to
put in a [ __ ] bottle the I don't know
dude I would say yeah I don't even know
what you were talking about good luck I
don't know I don't know enough about it
sir you're you're you're talking some
sort of [ __ ] science DNA [ __ ] and you
know you friend and I don't feel bad
that I can't give you advice because
you've heard me try to read out loud
so you know what you were getting
involved in okay that's the deal all
right all right
underrated everybody hey there Rudolph
the Red Nosed Reindeer that's a good one
about a year and a half ago I found out
my [ __ ] now ex-wife had cheated on me a
lot three different guys oh boy well she
earned the [ __ ] see where itself all
right - at the same time like I said
[ __ ] but now that I'm over although the
sadness so I don't nobody get [ __ ]
through still throw on the seat we okay
maybe over this sadness you still got
the anger though but now that I'm over
all the sadness and insecurity I
realized I'd been missing out on so many
things I have a good job and now I
travel alone for vacation and on my most
recent trip I even met a lady that's
great good for you you turned it around
as I'm typing this I'm at the mall
buying candles and eating frozen yogurt
alone and I love it
enjoy being single it's gonna be a very
small part of your life so enjoy it I'm
even going to treat myself to a trip to
New Orleans to New Orleans I'm from
Detroit to see you in January good for
you being able to laugh about my
situation when I heard you ran about
cheating [ __ ] helped me get through
some really hard times thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah no worries no what
are you gonna hey you know being in
relationships a tough thing everybody
makes mistakes I've [ __ ] made with
every goddamn mistake you could possibly
make you know so when you're single and
you're [ __ ] out there you know enjoy
it because I'm telling you it's gonna be
the [ __ ] it's gonna be a very short
time in your life because when you meet
the person you're supposed to make it
you know married to you're not gonna
want to leave them but then you know
you're in that and the relationship
keeps changing you know your
boyfriend/girlfriend it's the new thing
now it's getting a little old then you
move in together and you get [ __ ]
married then you have a kid it just
keeps [ __ ] changing and you know
there's definitely I don't think like
this much but there was definitely times
I think early on where you look back to
those days when you were single and it
was just like god that was [ __ ] great
but fortunately I don't think that I
think a lot of times I did think that
because I was so afraid of getting
married and I had met this person that I
knew I was never gonna get I was never
gonna break up with so I was like [ __ ]
you know like one of my this is I hate
to say this one of the best
Thanksgivings I ever had was the last
Thanksgiving I was single and uh I
actually hung out with this other comic
and we bought like a [ __ ] we bought
like a [ __ ] I think a case of
Budweiser cans and we were sitting in my
apartment and we ordered food and we
watched the football game and we just
laughed our [ __ ] asses off and got
[ __ ] hammered and then went out and
continued to drink
it was perfectly both in the same place
in our life he was in a relationship I
was in a relationship and we were just
talking about how we [ __ ] up every
relationship we'd ever been in and how
[ __ ] relieved that we were that we
weren't in relationships about ready to
ruin some poor woman's [ __ ] life as
they was spending yet another [ __ ]
holiday without dumbasses and we just
got shit-faced and just laughed and just
told all these [ __ ] stories about
what [ __ ] morons we were we drank the
whole [ __ ] day I don't even know if
I'd maybe had a turkey sandwich but I
wouldn't trade that obviously for what I
have now but I will tell you that that
was that this there's something to be
said about that and if you're not happy
in a relationship get out of it and when
you are single do not rush into another
one cuz you're lonely enjoy being
[ __ ] single because I'll tell you
right now there is a whole bunch of
[ __ ] people right now in
relationships that they don't want to be
in in this time of year it's [ __ ]
brutal you're going out there having to
buy a gift for someone that you're
trying to think when the [ __ ] can I
can't break up with them now because
it's the holiday then you got that
[ __ ] short window between the
holidays and then Valentine's Day you
know March is a good time to break up
with somebody it's right before spring
you know all you got is Saint Patrick's
Day you know this let's let's here we go
I'll get in the podcast top months to
break up with somebody
alright top top three months to do it
top three months not to do it alright
March provided the person's birthday
isn't in March March is a great one
September is a great time to pull the
ripcord it's it's before the holidays
start you know you're cleaning a house
to begin the end of the year I think
these are my top three I'll you give me
your top three and
I'll give you mine are my top three
March September March is [ __ ] great
all right because that means you took
him out for [ __ ] Valentine's Day you
weren't [ __ ] feeling it or they took
you out and you just what [ __ ] toy get
eyes and you're gonna break up with them
they're gonna be out of your [ __ ]
life and you're gonna get through the
sadness and right when you do the
[ __ ] Springs Springs here right
get out your rollerblades and start
[ __ ] skating around right September I
already told you why it's before the
[ __ ] holidays you're never gonna see
that person's [ __ ] parents again
right just [ __ ] get out of it or this
stupid roommate or whatever the [ __ ] it
is that's but I mean this isn't really
my experience because I actually dated
some really great people that I [ __ ]
all of those up I'm just saying alright
and then last one oh god this is tough
one the third one's a tough one
I don't think summertime is a good time
to break up with somebody right before
this summer
ooh March and September were easy I
don't know I would say you know I'm sure
that's promised to say I'm gonna go May
it's got thrown way out there you know
[ __ ] it you got the NHL and NBA playoffs
you want to [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] you
know she already ruined March Madness
for you get the [ __ ] out inmate those
are my 3 March September and then may
Mays a week that's a week one maybe
there's only those maybe there's just
two alright worse months to break up
with somebody I'm gonna say see the
worst month to break up with somebody
December right before Christmas that's
also a great time though because then
you don't have to [ __ ] go to the
other person's place Jesus I
I really talked myself into a corner
here I don't think there's a bad month
to break up with somebody
I guess it's this you know something I
just learned something it's never bad
when do you break up with somebody just
get the if you're not happy coz there's
nothing just get the [ __ ] out it's never
worse it's never worse than stay it in
I can't flag days coming again get the
[ __ ] out there you go
you know eyes get up well the last thing
I keep saying this the last thing this
is the [ __ ] last thing and then we
have a shot of eggnog and they try to go
to bed with all that sugar coursing
through my [ __ ] brains had the
[ __ ] eggnog dreams [ __ ] elves
attacking me and [ __ ] the [ __ ] was I
just gonna talk about breaking up with
somebody that I forget am I now thinking
about eggnog that's how my brain works I
[ __ ] left that thing it's like it's
like a [ __ ] train it just keeps going
that was back at the last station you
know that's it you never get it back you
leave if you left your pocket boy okay
it's a [ __ ] train I can't back up the
[ __ ] was they thinking about oh I get
such a kick out of this time of year
because I hated when I was on the
[ __ ] fence you know I wanted to get
married but I was afraid to get married
this time of [ __ ] year when they
start doing that [ __ ] about the
engagement rings those [ __ ] at
the advertising agencies they know they
know to drop those [ __ ] goddamn they
know when to do it when she's gonna be
sitting next to you and you just like
god that's a [ __ ] guide you I am so
[ __ ] relieved that I am past that
part my [ __ ] life alright that is it
that is the podcast everybody so there
you go so who do you like in the Super
Bowl I want to hear do you think the
Kansas City Chiefs I don't know I'm
still questioning their defense you know
I'm not questioning their [ __ ]
offense and that was a huge [ __ ] win
for that franchise to go into Foxborough
cuz we have definitely been a [ __ ]
spur under the
saddle or whatever that [ __ ] thing is
a goddamn pebble in there we're rocking
this shoe for the last couple of [ __ ]
years so congratulations them do you
think that they have what it takes to
get past the Baltimore Ravens aka the
Cleveland Browns I don't know
I'm a little nervous about my Seattle
pick but I'm still stumped staying with
the Seattle Seahawks winning Pete
Carroll gets ring number two
all right I'm sticking with it all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
or not Thursday